what's going on everybody welcome to yet
another Q&A in this Q&A we're gonna be
talking about a few things but first
we're gonna open some mail I got a
couple of boxes behind me and I'm pretty
sure I know what they are but let's see
so too big to put on my desk and show
you what that's okay that's it guys
that's what I got
pretty cool huh no that's dead Python
hats that's one of the boxes another one
of these fantastic items
Python shirts thing that looks pretty
good so after I launched the campaign so
if you didn't know I did an IndieGoGo
campaign to do start these shirts you
didn't know about the hats even if you
didn't know about the campaign but I did
find out shirts and Python hoodies and
we did reach the goal and all that so
I've got everything I'm still waiting on
the hoodie so I'll probably show those
probably hopefully by the next Q&A we'll
see I'm expecting to get those anytime
now but well actually they haven't even
been shipped they yeah they're still in
production so who knows all right now on
to the QA so I got a lot of questions
basically on scheduling basically how do
i schedule my day as well as how do I
actually like plan out and schedule or
like I guess more so like plan out my
videos the tutorial videos so both of
these things have changed pretty
significantly over time and they're
probably going to change again in the
future but I can tell you kind of how
things are going right now
so generally like my typical day is I
alway cup drink protein shake drink some
coffee while I'm doing that I'm reading
like reddit news stuff like that also
like Python reddit I'm catching up on
like YouTube comments emails the plus
equals one contacts that kind of stuff I
pretty much do that until I'm done
drinking my coffee
then I usually work out go for a biker
or run or something like that sometimes
both I live really close to some really
nice like trails like they're actually
City made kind of trails through
relatively scenic locations so it's a
great place to kind of ride your bike or
go run or both I usually ride my bike to
a park and then I lock it up and then I
go for a run so I'll do that come back I
will then eat something shower and all
that and then I actually start my real
like work day where I'm actually like
doing something and that could be all
kinds of things it could be something
with any one of my businesses it could
be contracting it could be consulting it
could be sure making a tutorial filling
a tutorial who knows so that's that so
that's kind of how I how I plan my day
and generally like I will work either
until I'm just exhausted and I'm just I
can I don't know you can just kind of
feel sometimes when you're
like you're you're done mentally and at
that point nothing's gonna get done at
that point so I'll quit but for the most
part I'll work until usually like eight
or nine or something like that sometimes
later if I'm like really into something
I'll work where I'll work too like
midnight or something and just basically
work from like 7:00 a.m. to midnight and
skip everything else it just really
depends so on to the next thing
basically how do I actually play in the
actual videos themselves this has
changed a lot too I used I used to like
I would like write the script first like
the actual Python script and then I
would kind of like memorize that and
then I would go through and tried to do
this before and then there were other
times where I would just kind of like
free just do this tutorial without even
really thinking about it and just see
how that went
my biggest thing now is I actually try
to just record a tutorial all the way
through without ever needing to edit the
video if I have to edit the video I I
just it's annoying because if I can
record it all the way through like with
xsplit which is what I'm recording on
right now you're just getting my webcam
but you can set scenes in xsplit it's
really mostly I think for streamers but
you can use it to record and you can
record your desktop and a webcam at the
same time you could throw in pictures
and stuff and it's really easy to record
all the way through and then you don't
have to throw it into something like
Sony Vegas to do the editing and then
rendering and all that and then for
whatever reason when I render a lot of
times things can just go wrong like
video and audio can get out of sync and
I already have problems with video and
audio sync I don't need anymore so my
biggest goal is just to record all the
way through and ever since I launched
Python programming on it I found that I
really just would want to neglect doing
the tech space write-ups so I do the
video and it might take me weeks to do
the tech space write-ups with the
tutorials so kind of the thing that I'm
doing now is I will first write the
text-based version of the tutorial and
kind of go through it so that's the
first time I kind of go through the
content that I'm going to teach and then
from there I go teach it now depending
on what it is sometimes I'll have it up
like either oh you can't see it but
actually you can yeah this screen right
here also I now I have a 4k screen so
sometimes I actually
it on the other half of the screen now
so it really just depends I'll put it
somewhere and I'll usually just like put
up the code or something like that or
sometimes the text-based version of the
tutorial but for the most part I just
want to put up the code just so I can
reference that real quick especially if
I hit some sort of strange error and I'm
like what the heck is happening
so it really just depends sometimes I
will just go straight through without
really actually looking at anything and
a lot there's quite a few tutorials that
defer from the text-based version of
this tutorial but I try to I try to keep
them on the same as much as possible so
anyway hopefully that answers your
question also I got another question
there's actually an OK question but you
posted it on multiple videos unrelated
videos and I just I'm just gonna throw
it out there as a public service
announcement if you do that I just don't
answer your question ok all comments
that come through basically I get
comments in the order that they were
posted it has nothing to do with how old
the video is so if you post a new
comment on a really old video it still
goes right to the top of my comments I
get an email for it and everything
I'll see your comment so when people
like post double questions because they
really want me to see their question of
their comment or whatever I just ignore
it
same thing with emails if you send me an
email to the like the exact same email
to two email addresses at the same time
I hate that I'm not going to it I'm not
going to answer that email so I don't
mind it like if I miss your email and
then like three days later you try a new
email that's totally fine but please
don't send me double emails and don't
post the same comment on multiple videos
it just clogs up comments I already
can't respond to all of the comments and
I also can't respond to all my emails so
those two things really just just really
get me going anyway there's that if
that's you I'm not gonna call you out
but if that's you feel free to post your
comment again just once on this video
and I will answer your question other
than that I think we're about set I did
find show this other comment is what are
your goals comments that's quite the
existential comment if you want to maybe
I don't know be a little more specific
on that comment let me know if not I'll
answer that at some point that's going
to be hard to condense into a single Q&A
but I'll do my best
alright in closing I just wanted to ask
for some time frames give me x in
central time that is my time for
streaming so my plan is to do some
streaming on various like code challenge
websites so you've got like project
Euler you've got advent of code hacker
rank Kegel I won't do any like it I
probably won't do any like existing paid
competitions for Kaggle just because
there's so many rules and regulations
for those but there's a lot of like
older ones or free ones and stuff
they're really great competitions to
like even though the competitions or
just like the challenges and kind of I
forget if they call them homework I
forget what they call them but like
research questions stuff like that
anyway there's a bunch of these
competition sites the ones that I have
let me just go through I got code Wars
hacker rant kaggle project Euler Python
channel let me pull that one up advent
of code I'm not sure which would know
literally Python challenge comm
if you have any other ones that you
really want to add to the list let me
know but more importantly I want to know
what kind of times would you want to see
streams of solving these kinds of
problems so my goal for the stream is to
just kind of have the stream be very
much a two-way street I don't want to
just be like solving these problems on a
stream I'd like to be solving them with
everyone on stream so it's kind of
important that we I try to accommodate
as many times as I can so yeah it just
give me times in central time if you
don't know how to convert central time
that's really fine just go to Google and
literally type whatever time you would
like in your time zone converted to CT
and Google will do it for you so anyways
leave those below otherwise I'll see you
guys in another video